yesterday i was being interviewed by
nomad capitalist the guy named andrew
who has lived in a hundred different
countries and he teaches people
how to have dual citizenships and he
owns uh properties in five different
countries that's what he does he's all
about leave america
because there's better places to live
than america
he asked me a question he says are you
an america fan i said die hard
he says tell me what you mean by that i
said i'm a die-hard
america fan of what it was founded on
america to me
is the values of principles which is
what freedom of speech freedom of
assembly freedom of religion freedom of
your second amendment free enterprise
that stuff the moment that changes
it's no longer america to me it's a
completely different
name to me so the moment certain states
and what california is experiencing
right now as well as new york when
you're 20 years old guess where you want
to live
you want to live in la you want to live
in well you live in miami partying in
miami it's probably going to be better
than partying in l.a quite frankly if
you think about it miami party is pretty
legit
so but when you're younger you're like
i'm in la hollywood i'm in new york city
all this stuff and you start kind of
making money
and you start having a family and you
start kind of saying well
i just don't know if these are some of
the you know things that i want to be
around
i want to kind of have a little bit more
flexibility and freedom then you start
looking
and then if america goes in the tipping
point and they really start pushing
around
the populace i i just think it would be
like you know how with business when you
see somebody that's totally screwing up
like sears is screwing up you're leaving
an opportunity okay for others to come
in
when you saw blockbuster royally getting
arrogant as an
8 billion dollar company screwing up
with the late fees remember how annoying
it was with blockers
dude just wipe it wait take it off no
i said i'm paying you 30 bucks for this
movie to buy brand new is 15 bucks
waive the damn late fee put a limit of
the value of the dvd
no i'm not going to be doing it yours 30
bucks after doing that to tens of
thousands of people you're like you know
what i'm sorry i just can't stand the
way you treat customers
i'm out of here now there's only one
left and we interviewed the manager the
one blockbuster that's left
i don't know where it's at seattle or
washington or something like that
i think today there's a great
opportunity
for a handful of countries to become a
second option
i think today's a great opportunity for
a handful of countries to say you know
what
we kind of see america that's been what
everybody wanted to be like
what if we see the mistakes america's
made and we give that safety to people
to come over here
what if we change it up okay what if we
change it up how many people are gonna
move
not many but all it takes is a couple
people that move influential and then
if and only if america royally
gets cocky arrogant egotistical kind of
like the city of detroit
went from 200 000 people to 1.8 and next
thing you know the municipalities
there's city employees the government
people started kind of pushing people
around
ford said listen forget about it you're
right we're out of here people started
leaving they went from 1.8 million
people living in new york city richest
city in the world
to you know 700 000 people living there
today if you call
9-1-1 i don't know if we covered this on
the last podcast if you call 9-1-1 in
in detroit city today's the re it's the
poorest city and it's the most dangerous
city to live in america today today
poorest and most dangerous lowest it's
the worst city today based on
economical freedom and safety right you
call 9-1-1 today do you know how long it
takes for cops to show up
59 minutes let me say this one more time
if you dial 9-1-1
it takes more than 50 minutes for cops
to show up
if you call 9-1-1 today you call him you
tell him
kai said this in the room you call him
you tell him i'm about to rob the bank
you go rob the bank it takes you 20
minutes to do it you leave and they
still haven't shown up
right so what does this mean with
america if america gets too cocky and
arrogant start pushing people around
i think people will be looking at going
elsewhere if you look at a lot of people
where are you from oh i'm irish
their family left ireland to come here
where are you from i'm jewish okay your
family left
israel where are you from norway your
family left were you from mexico mifa
iran were you
so if people from other countries are
willing to move to a country like this
people will be eventually forced to
leave america if america gets too cocky
you guys have any opposing opinions on
what i just said i know you want to say
like marco was
uh just look obviously
we're all very pro-american and and we'd
love it here but
you know it's easy to say well you know
you just leave america oh i'll just
leave him right but
where are you actually going did you
hear what i said earlier yeah okay
what did i say regarding what i said if
same way blockbuster lost people this is
a great opportunity to be a netflix
i agree with you so a uh uh a uh uh
belize a costa rica
not canada no i'm not saying now i'm
saying they could
they could be i know a lot of people
that moved to costa rica
dubai is a place that's attracting a lot
of people now
living there is a different kind of a
lifestyle so you're gonna have to ask
about the pool of talent
the benefits of talent so the guy asked
me question he says you know he
he was in uh somewhere in central
america is where he was at the country
he was staying at
i said so for he says would you consider
as a certain industry could do that not
all industries could do that like he's a
guy that does online courses
things like that you can live where
anywhere engineers anywhere
coders anywhere certain industries you
can't go
anywhere so the challenge would be the
only challenge when i processes it is
what
pool pool of talent but if you have a
place
i tell you right now if we had a country
i'm telling you right now if we had a
country right now
somehow somewhere we got 10 million
people and we got a good amount of land
right now decent weather some natural
resources
watch what we would do to that country
20 years later i'm telling you right now
if we had a country right now with 10
million people decent natural resources
some land give us 20 years look what we
would do to our citizens
look how much they would love living
where we live look the kind of
foundation and the values and principles
we will build that country
and look what kind of people would want
to live with us and you know what we
would do
we wouldn't allow everybody to come in
it wouldn't be one of those situations
where it's like a
it would be by invitation just like you
know if you want to be part of clubhouse
what do they do
you have to be invited right okay back
in the days a lot of these social media
platforms you have to be what
you have to be invited it'd be a similar
thing hey you're going to say pat i
think we got to let keith
in here tell me about keith dude we're
going to love keith let me what are you
talking about
have i ever brought anybody okay cool
bring keith in i think there would be an
element of that that we could build a
country with invite only yeah that was
the
origination of facebook remember that it
was it was college by college
and you had to be a student at that
college
those are the emails that you had so so
i agree
i don't see a valid viable option to
today there are some singapore new
zealand there are some
singapore is an option new zealand is an
option and quite frankly those would
probably at the top
five of places you would look at costa
rica isn't when i went to panama city
panama not panama city
like spinnakers or or you know club la
villa i'm talking panama city panama
next to nicaragua
yes when i went to panama city and i
played poker with the senator
i'm sitting there with them and i said
so where are you from oh i'm from dallas
oh very cool you vacation here often
he says no i've been living here for 11
years i said why'd you leave
so do you know the regulations here
unemployment here is 2.3 percent they
leave you alone you can do anything
here's
have you looked at the real estate of
panama matter if i go to panama type in
panama
real estate panama city panama real
estate
like buildings buildings buildings you
got to put buildings right
uh panama city buildings yeah uh
buildings uh
i hope it goes to the right panama city
put images like
right there like you ever seen anything
like that in u.s the fnf tower i've
never seen anything like this in u.s
right you you look at some of the right
there click on that one right there
luxury real estate look at that you know
you see some of the most beautiful stuff
now obviously i'm seeing stuff like this
in miami but
he says have you seen what we're doing
in panama city the next guy where are
you from chicago how long have you come
here
i've been living here for 10 years so
that gave a glimpse and i was 10 years
ago that gave me a glimpse that people
are considering moving to other
countries
from the u.s no no doubt and i know a
lot of people
especially people in south florida that
end up in costa rica what have you i i
guess
my point was yeah little pockets here go
to costa rica a little
you know maybe you go to little panama
like little tiny countries
maybe you end up in new zealand i guess
my macro question is what country is
gonna supplant
america i just don't see one right now
and i'm not being a cocky american like
oh you can't
compete with america i just like paul
joked and said canada i don't know if he
was joking or not
go check out the weather in canada nine
months out of the year good luck over
there so i'm just saying
you want to go to china go have fun in
china check it out in michigan
or you know well that's what you can
move from michigan
wait a minute no no no wait a minute let
me ask you this what was the richest
city in the world in 1950s
motown baby what was the temperature in
motown
80 degrees year-round do you know the
temperature in motion
that was because of thomas ford and you
know the industrial revolution and
making the cars and
which is huge or his brother henry ford
i mean uh thomas i was thinking of
thomas edison henry ford
you just thomas ford nikola ford right
he was a good guy
just me yeah without trying to make a
point
is one man changed a city
one it didn't take 50. it didn't take a
hundred one
person changed the city forever
ford came in created jobs everybody
moved in
other automakers went there mo tank came
out of there michael jackson diana ross
you know all of those
names of who came out meaning the the
records who signed them
all of that is from motown detroit okay
they call it the paris of the west
a paris of the midwest detroit so and
weather sucked there it's not about the
weather don't get me wrong i give credit
to california whether it's got to be the
miami weather totally i get it weather
is very important
i'm not going to go i was about to move
to naperville chicago a friend of mine
jeff had a place
i was going to go i wanted to run with
the guy for a couple decades right but
i'm like yeah i'm good i'm
much better being in la or much better
being in florida but that's my
preference
but if it comes down to it and they
force people
would rather follow a leader an
environment that gives you
safety and freedom and they'll give up
a little bit of weather they'll give up
a little bit of other things to have
freedom there's nothing in your life
that's more important to you than
freedom
nothing when you have it you don't know
you have it you know how
when you when your body is doing well
you don't think about
any potential pain then you start having
back pain
and what you say i'll give anything to
get rid of this back pain
then you get coveted you're throwing up
all over the place and to do it i'll
give
anything i'll give anything to get rid
of this right
yeah when you have freedom you don't
know you have it people don't know
they have freedom they don't know so but
when it's taken away then you're gonna
say there's
no way in the world i can live like this
for the rest of my life i'm willing to
go to a different place
because i just want to be free uh just
so um listen the chance of us getting
there's less than one percent just so
people know it's not a big chance we're
not putting
going to vegas right now betting a
hundred thousand dollars because you
know america is
going to go down but that one percent
chance is a chance where you should have
a hedge
you should hedge against it and have
your own insurance policy in case things
do happen and can i clarify one thing
uh adam kind of made fun when i was
talking about canada
i was talking more vancouver which a lot
of americans have been moving to in
montreal
freezing they have been stealing
business from hollywood a lot of
productions are going to canada
and doing something and so those were
two of the examples i was thinking of
when i said canada has a huge
opportunity they've already uh
pounced on that opportunity and i could
see them continuing to grow that's just
my bottom it's just a very powerful uh
point you just made with what's
happening over there with austin even
getting
business away from hollywood pat one
counterpoint with that but is
aren't you like the detroit example
because my dad's from detroit knee i
ended up moving to florida in the 60s so
i'm familiar with this
but aren't you sort of highlighting the
beauty of america it's like well if
you're unhappy in that state
move to a different state that means
exactly what's playing out right now
with california new york and why people
are moving to florida
tennessee texas isn't that
sort of the point of america that you
know states rights that
certain states are screwing up like you
did an awesome video about is new york
the next detroit
you can move to a different state right
you don't have to move to a different
country i just don't see the country
yeah that's gonna but
usurp america sure if federal
government has more power than state
level the state didn't decide to get a
1.9 trillion dollar
stimulus but that 1.9 trillion dollar
stimulus affects
people living in any state including
south dakota that maybe wasn't affected
by covey fair enough
like a place like california was
affected by so yes federally
you are still getting side effects of
bad decisions being made at the top of
the government you will be affected by
it
all i'm saying is this is a great time
for another country to position
themselves
when rick perry was coming to the state
of california and he was saying
you're running you've heard me say this
you're running a business you're not
happy regulation come to texas come to
texas now guess who's doing it today
the two of the most hated governors in
america today are who abbott and
desantis why you know you know when i
talked to ron kim yesterday
he said something very interesting and i
was like why would you say that he said
he said i don't think it's a good
strategy to recruit citizens from other
states to your state purely
based on the economy i'm like that's the
whole idea
what are you talking about people went
to new york because you're recruiting
people
to economy and he said he made a comment
which
by the way i can't wait to have ron back
again we had a great hour conversation
in this course
and there was a debate in banter where
he's saying his side is well i know who
you are of course i follow your stuff
but i got to tell you here's what i
stand you came in america we both came
here as immigrants i'm 41 you're 42.
my dad owned a liquor store or a grocery
store after 10 years they had to shut it
down and all this other stuff
and i said okay so if you have personal
experience as i said you went to this
you decided to go into business i went
into public
so you wanted to be an entrepreneur i
went to public he said
i don't think it's a good strategy to
take people away from businesses and
then i said
what about the fact that a division of
goldman sachs is leaving peter's
all this stuff is leaving and he says
yeah
it's okay that financial people are they
didn't say it's okay that financial
people are leaving but he's saying
it's the financial folks that are
leaving but we're building our own tech
hub like silicon valley in new york city
that's what's growing if the financial
people do what they do
let them do what they do but we're
building a technology
center like a hub like a silicon valley
in new york city
so you know it's it's uh it's
interesting but more power to desantis
and
abbott but imagine if now it's a country
now imagine you're a president and you
go
and you have an accent whatever part of
the world you are hey this is president
such and such
okay and you go on the media and you're
talking 50 different media platforms bbc
whatever all these other places sky news
australia all these places you talk and
you say
americans i can't believe i'm saying
this
but from a person who admires your
country and what it was founded on i am
surprised on what is happening today
to your country here's a country that
was able to do in 200 years what china
couldn't do in 2000 years
here's a country that was able to go
from nothing
just because of some land you became the
most powerful country in the world
here's a country that went from having
this kind of a gdp to doing this kind of
a gdp
here's a country that gave birth to
rockefeller franklin
chase you go through the list of great
entrepreneurs
but unfortunately we all know you're no
longer
the america you used to be and if you're
somebody that's looking at options
let me explain to you what we at our
country
are doing we protect this we
protect that the five concerns that you
may face is this this this
here's how we have protected your long
term and all i suggest
is before you even think about moving to
our country i suggest
you come here for vacation for three
four days and see how you like it
and we are given 500 tax credits if you
come here
from america come pay a visit to us and
see if you like that
if you do we would love for you to
consider to bring your talents
and your resources to our country at 300
000
deposits you bring to our country we
give you citizenship
and with the benefit of our citizenship
you get the following boom boom boom
boom boom
if that starts happening with another
country recruiting people away from
america and that country has something
to offer
[Laughter]
it's going to get very interesting
because you can run a business out of
any country and you're zooming in
you can have people you're running it
from all over the place you can zoom in
right i got people working for us from
armenia we got people working for us
from india we got people working for us
from
colombia we got people all over the
place because they can work remotely so
if something like that were to happen
america
could see somewhat of people being
comfortable knowing that if
you know america goes the wrong
direction have a second choice i can go
somewhere else would you
secretly or even not so secretly
actually
love to see that abs i wouldn't i would
i would secretly and publicly
never want to see that ever once you do
not want to see that
ever in a billion years i would never
want to see that
ever zero not even point zero one
percent
ever want to see that happen but you
know what i would love to see happen i
would love to see a country
get to a point that they have the
resources
and the offer to get others to consider
that you
could leave i'd love to have a country
that's an option too
where america realizes there is option
too
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye